[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance case closed
lost in the laughs out loud funny
statement to the Senate Intelligence
Committee from Jared Kushner lost in the
understandable confusion over Trump's
plaintive cry for protection from the
Republican Party who are they supposed
to protect him from Putin lost during
the understandable anxiety about what
Trump will do next for Titanic facts
have now emerged their importance cannot
be overstated the conclusion they lead
to cannot be avoided we have all been
right all this time the essence of the
conspiracy case against Donald Trump his
presidential campaign is presidential
administration and the government of
Russia has for all intents and purposes
been proven these four titanic facts are
barring the most bizarre and unexpected
of exculpatory explanations one the now
Attorney General of the United States
reportedly lied about meeting and
discussing the campaign with and
colluding with the Russian ambassador to
this country during the campaign and two
that he did so provides another
indication that the Trump presidential
campaign sought to conspire to do a deal
with a foreign nation to interfere with
our elections and three the president's
son-in-law and advisor now admits he
asked the Russians to give the Trump
transition team access to Russian
controlled communications channels to
talk directly to the Kremlin last
December and for that the Trump
presidential administration seems to
have orchestrated and enacted a
full-scale multi-tier venal indefensible
plot to cover up those activities by the
Trump campaign that were disloyal to the
United States of America in short if the
Washington Post and the intelligence
intercepts it quotes are accurate
between the perfidy of Jeffrey
Beauregard sessions the email chain of
Donald Trump jr. and Kushner's blyve and
run around formal legal communications
links to the Kremlin it is case closed
the Trump gang is guilty at best they
only tried and failed to do a deal with
the Russians they are at this moment
covering it up the machinery of the law
and the government and the loyal
citizens of the United States need to be
removing them all of them from the White
House and need to be removing those who
are defending them and placing party
before country all of them from any
position of authority in any branch of
government local or national and this
needs to be done immediately so that
there is no confusion about this let's
put two seemingly separate stories
together in June 2016 Trump jr. Kushner
and Paul Manafort met with four people
at least one of whom they believed was a
middleman for the Russian government
willing to interfere with the American
electoral process what happened next is
important but it is not decisive at that
meeting they all created a structure
equivalent to holding up the liquor
store it doesn't matter if the bottles
were empty and there are intelligence
sources reporting that the Russian
ambassador to the United States
confirmed to his masters in the Kremlin
that in April 2016 and July 2016 he
discussed with sessions on behalf of the
Trump campaign the policies which an
incoming Trump administration could bend
to serve Russia what happened here next
is important but not decisive either
they all created a structure equivalent
to Aldrich Ames selling out a hundred or
more American spies for two and a half
million dollars it doesn't matter if
Jeff Sessions doesn't know his quid from
his pro quo and now Kushner has
submitted this statement to the Senate
in which he claims he read some parts of
an email invitation to meet with
Russians to get Hilary dirt but not
others and he attended the meeting
anyway and he admits the communications
request and admits contacts with Russian
officials without ever wondering why
they wanted to meet with him it is a
conspiracy and if these stories are
correct that means with Trump in
office sessions lied to the Senate about
his conspiracy with Russia and while in
office
Trump's administration has reportedly
been searching for information to use to
smear Bob Muller to help cover up this
conspiracy with Russia and while in
office Trump fired Comey to cover up
this conspiracy with Russia and while in
office
Trump reportedly personally signed off
on Trump Jr's untrue statement about
this conspiracy with Russia the only
conclusion is that there is a White
House cover-up led by Donald Trump to
hide a conspiracy with Russia there are
many additional details that link the
chain of events more strongly still
Trump's adlib promise of a speech about
Russian dirt on Hillary Clinton three
hours after his son confirmed that
meeting Carter Paige going to Russia
then meeting with kis lyac in Cleveland
Trump asking the Russians to find the
Clinton emails Trump reportedly
divulging classified information to the
Russians in the Oval Office trump
meeting with Putin at the g20 with no
other Americans present this is what we
know it is impossible for anybody to
believe that this is all the authorities
know sessions appears to have been
compromised by the Russians for at least
15 months and he is apparently perjured
himself before the Senate on two
separate occasions Trump jr. Kushner and
mana Ford have been compromised by the
Russians for at least 13 months and
Trump himself either knew none of this
and was thus what is called in
intelligence circles an unwitting agents
of the Russians and has been compromised
by them since the day he met kis lyac or
he knew some or all of it and he has
been far worse than that for structure
for motive for what evidence we have
seen so far the case is closed
now the Trump campaign was willing to
accept what it believed was material
from the Russian government for use in
our presidential election Trump family
members and top-level campaign leader
met with the Russian ambassador to the
United States to reportedly discuss how
Trump would then change American policy
to benefit Moscow candidate Trump urged
the Russians to hack the computers of
his opponent and the computers of her
party were already being hacked the
president-elect son-in-law tried to
establish a secret communications
network with which to talk to the
Kremlin case closed
the New York Times unearthed the
document from special counsel Kenneth
Starr's investigation of Bill Clinton
insisting that a sitting president can
be indicted John Dean the White House
Counsel - the only president ever to
resign says if Trump or an attorney
general of any name tries to fire
special counsel Muller
Muller can go to court to prevent the
firing and he can win and Trump cannot
pardon himself and anybody he does
pardon loses the right to use the Fifth
Amendment to avoid testimony at an
impeachment or in court impeach convict
and arrest Donald John Trump resist
remove peace